thank you
Sonia are we live
good afternoon everyone and welcome to
the policy and Regulatory meeting today
um we've just got the one formal step to
go through and then I will
move on and explain how how the day will
run
so do we have any apologies I have one
apology from near Ben Bell are there any
others
being none can I have a move of the
apology be accepted please from
councilor or Joe and seconded from
glennis
Senate and upon an apology from Andrea
mcphail right thank you Angela sorry
Angela yes
all right so we have one item on the
agenda today to deal with a report from
the cat
um
management and control subcommittee
and
um
the outline just in terms of the process
that we'll follow
we'll hear from the chair of the
subcommittee which is glennis Dixon and
we will then have a series of
presentations from members of the
committee and one of those presentations
will be by video
and then we'll hear from the the other
person's present
and you might like to come up now and
sit at the table and introduce
yourselves please
now someone might need to help in terms
of turning the speakers on
my name is
the Environmental arm from
my name is Andrea McMullen and I'm one
of the community Representatives
yes hello I'm Melanie Ferguson and I'm a
community representative
thank you Shelley Melanie and Andrea
welcome and we will hear from you
shortly so after we've heard the
presentations from the three
um we'll then have questions from
counselors and any questions that staff
may also have if counselors can please
hold off during the presentation so that
we have all the questions and one go
together at the end
the report that we've received has a
series of recommendations and I want to
then consider them generally one at a
time and I will change the order of them
a little bit and also to consider any
other
issues that councilors may wish to raise
for the information of the lay people
present and also for the public watching
this is a committing meeting today in
any decisions that are made require
ratification at full Council next month
so are there any questions in terms of
the process that we're going to be using
today
otherwise counselor Dixon I will hand
over to you for your presentation please
thank you Mr chair the report attached
represents the findings and
recommendations of the cap management
working group for your consideration
firstly I'd like to thank in Maxwell the
administrator and hakanui runanga and
the community representatives for their
input into this report some of it who
will be speaking to the report today
there is a lack of national guidelines
and policy regarding cap management in
general although nationally it's
estimated there are millions of feral
cats causing health issues and nuisance
living on our indigenous Wildlife for
survival
there's also a lack of public awareness
as to the nature and extent of
Australian feral cats in the district as
a community volunteers will allude to
today
they are estimated to be 2 200 owners of
approximately
3500 companion cats which are really to
clarify their household pets
500 to 700 stray cats and four thousand
to four thousand feral cats four
thousand four thousand three hundred
feral cats in the gore District
it's important to note
the working group supports responsible
owners of companion cats as we realize
the importance of pets to families
the working group considers Council has
a role in achieving effective Care
Management given the social economic and
environmental and environmental impacts
on our district
The Local Government Act 2002 in the
health act 1956 provides Council
council's authority to create bylaws on
management and we are presently waiting
on the environmental committee to report
back to government on this issue
management working group advocates for
the enactment of national legislation by
government mandating desexing and
microchipping of all companion cats and
for environment South and to control
feral cats in the gore District
the cap management working group
recommends Council note our
well-informed in research Provisions in
the report and Generator cap management
policy and thank the Regulatory and
planning committee for their time today
thank you councilor
um so I guess we'll now hear from
Shelley Melanie and Andrea and can I
suggest you go from one side to the
other
um hello everyone as mentioned I'm from
the tire town the environmental arm of
the hokanuranga um
so the Thai team have made significant
progress in the past two years and ho
Moody caught in Boston Park area
administering pest control operations
focusing on the trapping of possums rats
and mustards in the area and there's
been a noticeable increase in the bird
life in these areas and with hope that
with our continued Pest Control programs
the fauna and our native Forest gets a
chance to regenerate the recommendations
made in this report are fully supported
by hokanui of council has a clear
position and policy regarding cats and
the gore and surrounding areas that
reduces the impact of cat predation on
our native wildlife
I'd also like to take this opportunity
to acknowledge these ladies and glennis
our chairwoman who've been involved in
the Care Management working group
um some have been working tirelessly
behind the scenes for many years from
their own pockets and home to trap
noodle vaccinate and re-home unwanted
and Stray Cats within the goal area
um they saw a problem and took it upon
themselves to act
the problem is far greater than a few
people working individually and would be
far more beneficial operating from a
computer a community in Council level
thank you very much
entry
I apologize in advance for my voice so
I've been talking since about seven
o'clock this morning and I'm on the
verge of losing my voice
thank you all for the opportunity to
talk to you today Kia Ora my name is
Andrea McMillan I've lived in the gore
Community for the past 30 years and an
e-score for 20 of those 30 years I work
as a registered nurse in the community
specializing in Occupational Health
previously I volunteered for the gore
and districts SPCA around 2006 for about
eight years with several of those years
as assistant manager on a voluntary
basis during approximately 15 hours a
week
I reluctantly gave this up when my son
was diagnosed with a serious illness
however I've continued to
be involved assisting others in the
community with Animal Welfare issues
helping re-home cats assisting and
financially helping people desex their
cats transporting cats to and from the
vet Etc
I used to mate I probably received two
to three calls a week often from people
I don't know I probably spend
approximately a hundred and fifty
dollars a week of my own income
I am a Community member of the newly
formed gauquette rescue and I've worked
for several years with other rescue
groups across Gore and Southland
being that I have an interest in Animal
Welfare I've noticed over the past few
years particularly around where I live
in East Gore an increase in number of
cats in general Stray Cats Colony Cats
and feral cats
I by no means I'm doing as much as some
people in the community however I cannot
sit back and do nothing
it would be easier to tune a blind eye
but for those of us that go above and
beyond and are stepping up our moral and
social conscience does not allow us to
do nothing
rescue workers emotionally and
financially taxing it is often thankless
and most of us have been abused more
than once
I feel privileged to have been on the
council cat working party who have
researched ideas networked respected
others opinions and are showing a
willingness to learn about The Unwanted
undersexed stray cat colony problem we
find ourselves amongst
thank you for recognizing that there is
a problem in Goa in establishing the cat
working party this is a great starting
point to build on
from my experience and from what I see
and hear from others the problem is
escalating
I consider this to be due to multiple
factors cost of living crisis housing
crisis covert and the formal closure of
the gore industry in the closure of the
Gorham District's East PCA in 2020
until the closure of the local SPCA
shelter people at least had somewhere to
take their unwanted animals that they
could no longer keep now they just dump
them
and in rule the community doesn't know
where to go to seek help to be effective
we need to work as a community the
residents of Gore don't know what to do
or where to tune when faced with issues
the litters of kittens are getting
bigger and bigger as in there are more
kittens breeding and those curtains are
having kittens and so on it goes
there are various people and go working
behind the scenes capturing desexing
socializing and rehiming but the problem
is growing at a faster rate than what a
handful of volunteers can manage
we all have families work and lives and
many of us are juggling lifehoodles
then of course is the safety risk it's
dangerous being out there on your own at
night
we knew our responsible Peter owner
there is nothing more frustrating than
him to take your own animals to the vet
multiple times because of other cats
fighting your cats causing infectious
disease and injury
my wish list
a Maori face at a cohesive and United
approach with various groups working
together
as Gore Community leaders I'm requesting
that the council build on the work that
they are already doing namely the
establishment of the keep working party
I would like Council to have a clear
position a policy regarding the cat
problems in Goa
it would be helpful for the council to
take a leadership role in advocating to
the government for changes to
legislation
in his leader of the gore Community we
seek that the council become actively
involved
more importantly on a practical basis on
the ground here in Goa we want the
opportunity to be able to apply to
council for grant funding to enhance
animal welfare and desexing it is easier
to desex to avoid litters of kittens
than to find homes for them
in case you don't know cats can have up
to three to five litters of kittens a
year often with four to eight kittens in
each
I would also love to see the gore
District Council uses existing resources
to better educate residents consuming
responsible cat ownership
it would be awesome to see some local
bylaws limiting numbers of pets cats per
household I quite like cats but I do not
have 10 of them
I believe a good starting point would be
to build on the work already done by the
snaps program by offering subsidized
desexing as well as compulsory
microchipping
it is already well known that Australia
feel and unhealthy Cates can spread
disease but not only does the disease
that they suffer themselves is
horrendous such as lung worm and
toxoplasmosis to name two diseases
various councils have introduced
mandated microchipping in D6 in their
cats well Wellington city council was
the first to implement cake controls
updating its animal bylaw in 2016 to
introduce mandatory microchipping sodas
all doable
here's a scenario and I am nearly
finished by the way
Little Johnny get to cut him for
Christmas but so it's not lonely let's
get two of them because nobody can
afford it and life keeps happening by
Easter both kids who are still actually
kittens themselves and now having
kittens how cute
now it's not even winter in fact it's
only May and from those two two cute
kittens when they have at least 10
kittens and by this Christmas if not
neutered those kittens are having
kittens and on and on it goes
often with other people picking up the
social and economic problems
I beat you are hoping that little Johnny
doesn't live in your street
I often see this type of scenario on
social media it is not a far-fetched
example
one measure of community is how the
community looks after it's vulnerable
animals don't have a voice they don't
ask to be dumped unwanted or starving I
thank you for your time today namahi
thank you
Melanie
so I'm Melanie Ferguson and I'm a long
time Gore resident
I'd like to thank the council for
recognizing that there's a cat problem
and for establishing the cap Management
Group
I've been rescuing stray and abandoned
cats for the last four and a half years
my journey with cat rescue began when I
decided to tame and find homes for a
litter of kittens that were living
behind the subway building
and on driving down the main street at
10 pm I counted seven cats and kittens
looking for food in the rubbish bins
I've been going out almost every night
since to feed cats around the town at
times up to 30 in the night
but time these cats D6 vaccinate and
then re-home
today at I have re-homed over 130 I
haven't yet found one cat that wasn't
re-homeable
pets have been domesticated by humans
over thousands of years and yet the ones
unlucky enough
to be abandoned or born as strays
I looked upon his filthy nuisances
through no fault of their own
the problem stems from lack of desexing
and people dumping animals
and a recent deceased estate I was
called in to help rescue the cats and
ultimately found 21 on the property and
have since identified at least 30 that
came from this household this person
loved their pets but wasn't aware of the
importance of their sexing
I'm currently feeding a cat with zero
six month old kittens and she's already
had an X litter
when an unused pair of cats breed and
have on average two letters per year
averaging three surviving kittens per
liter within nine years around 11
million six hundred and six thousand
kittens will have been produced which is
really shocking
the closure of the local SPCA has left a
handful of private citizens to try to
cope with the situation
and the financial burden Industries has
been huge
the work that I've been doing over the
years has been largely self-funded
costs their family around 295 per week
on average I've been getting at least
one or two requests a week for help
regarding cats of concern most often
involved involving more than one cat
it's obvious that residents don't know
who to contact for help with these
issues
many people also reporting that pregnant
cats have been dumped in their area
these calls come from every part of our
community and more often than not the
cats are dumped pets
I believe there's a common misconception
that cats are able to adequately fend
for themselves my experience has shown
that this isn't true some of the issues
I've seen include that most cats have
lung worm when rescued as the hunger
forces them to eat things like slugs
which carry Lang worm larvae this often
leads to respiratory issues in death
a biscuited cat with a partially
amputated tail a kitten with
hindquarters Paralyzed by a spinal
infection and a kitten with a broken jaw
just as a few examples
so I can attest to the fact that these
cats suffer a lot and their lives are
not easy
without the SPCA there's also a lack of
governance over animal ownership and no
enforcement of welfare
I have limited capacity to help people
as I work from home
facility is therefore urgently needed to
house these cats and so that more can be
helped and gone off the streets
both invercargill and Dunedin SPCA are
also overrun and have been unable to
help the majority of the time
the situation has left me exhausted both
physically and mentally and I've been at
breaking point for some time now
most people who rescue animals typically
burn out due to being stressed
overwhelmed and unsupported
I believe that this needs a joined up
community-based solution including some
of the following
facility that meets regulations for
well-managed hygiene and Disease Control
funding for vet costs desexing food and
so on
and I believe Council has a role in
having a clear position in policy
regarding the cat problem and Gore
in addition we'd like the council to
take a leadership role and advocacy at
government level and to use as its
resources to better educate residents
concerning responsible care ownership in
particularly relating to the importance
of desexing thank you
thank you all three for your
presentations it's
one for speaking out to for being here
today it's appreciated I'll open it up
for questions from counselors please
oh sorry um there was there was a video
presentation thank you
um
cheers
because I do hope
I'm going to see
if we actually have a human problem
means that it's human actions or
in action
versus social things like this
individual action or it's not going to
solve the problem
the government
level not just at the national
government
s at local
and so I really do hope
I'd like to draw your attention to
to first of all of the cap Management
Group
firstly by
he said
around the control and reduction of the
problem
s in our districts
I also think there's a really
significant
are already Community groups out there
who are trying to help to manage the
care population and it would be
wonderful
job speaking from personal experience I
in Los Angeles
and we're trying to do some
Bridge we're trying to re-harm stray
cats
taking unwanted
paid off
the Drake out from
now
we have tried multiple Avenues and
is we are not getting the financial
Journey
to operate as a
as an event so I think there is a real
role for the council
I really do hope that the children
and so I would like to thank you for
your time
and urge you to adopt the
recommendations
and that's
okay I'll now open it up for questions
from councilors
Robert
um this is sort of a statement and a
question a lot of it seems to come back
to the fact that there's no SPCA in town
now
as you say there's nowhere for people to
go
to drop them off all there is but it's
not there anymore
now I'm not totally aware but why was
that villain closed down in town here
was it not up to scratch or something
excuse the pun
the consensus at the time and I wasn't a
member of the organization at the time
but I've just followed from afar was
that it was going to take up to five
hundred thousand dollars apparently to
get the building to comply
so it was resources
because you're probably aware Kath used
to come in to see me once a fortnight
and we did a show and we found homes for
a lot of cats but it was coming through
keth to me at the station and there was
people
um standing at the door waiting
sometimes when she was talking about
particular cats if we had a way of
getting something like that going again
whether it's through SPCA
obviously the people had to pay for
those cats because they reneuted and in
good health
before they could get them but I mean
I'm prepared to jump on board with doing
something like that again but it's it's
getting that base where people can go
somehow isn't it is that the big problem
yeah
ciao thank you thank you Mr
um yeah to you Andrea you mentioned in
your um your speech there about being
abused more than once and then later
referred to safety risks is that on
dealing with people with their cats or
what's the what's the meaning behind it
please
um I'll get my friend Mel
's as well because she's actually been
abused
horrendously not too long ago
mine's just largely verbal abuse
um
if I haven't been able to help somebody
solve a problem
um
verbally abuse particularly when I was
at the shelter
um
so good a good eight years ago 10 years
ago
um if you couldn't solve somebody's
problem instantly it was suddenly your
fault
um so a lot of verbal abuse yeah
but Mel has actually got a horrendous
example oh
um so because I go out every night to
feed cats I go out later at night
um largely so the public don't see me
um I've been
I had a couple of guys pull up in a car
Shine the headlights on me and and then
swear at me for feeding the cats and
drive away it was very intimidating
um and another man recently came very
close to assaulting me
and he was actually ironically somebody
who had actually asked for my help in
feeding cats so it wasn't actually to
deal with the fact that I was feeding
cats it was just probably yeah
a very risky what's risky being out late
at night I guess
to begin with
yeah
just to clarify for me but shouldn't the
first Paul to call for a phone call be
to your animal control contractor
if there's cats because that surely
comes under the agreement
maybe a staff member can help us on that
one
Steve the chief executive he's got a
speaker over the back
you through Mr chairman
um cats are not a normal part of the
remit of animal control
there's no specific Act of Parliament
that governs their
um their management so the animal
control arm of the council is
predominantly focused towards obviously
dogs which has its own particular
statute
and stock so stray stock of sheep cattle
horses pigs goats whatever so cats are
not really part of it and one of the
primary questions of this particular
committee and ultimate ultimately the
council
is to ascertain what it can do to
regulate the management and control of
cats
and obviously the initiatives that are
being
promoted in the cap management working
parties report
but without any uh director from the
council our staff are really
have no authority to get involved in the
regulation of cats and hence one of the
I think one of the critical questions
that the committee and Council need to
ask itself
is in terms of first developing a cap
management policy and one of the I guess
the big questions arising out of that is
should the council then commit itself to
developing a bylaw and then if it does
do a bylaw that's a this this particular
body of work is very useful because the
bylaw has to first ask to make a boiler
you've got to ask yourself what is the
problem that needs to be addressed what
is the most effective way of addressing
that problem and then the bylaw can in
turn
mandate that certain things will take
place so some of the speakers have
talked about a maximum number of cats
per property microchipping all those
things become possible under a bylaw a
sanctioned by the council
I didn't answer
also a question to the chief executive
please where is he gone hello
sorry
um I think I lost my train of thought
now horses
what was I going to ask if if there was
a um a regulation brought in that what
sort of a um an impact would that have
on Staffing levels and time commitments
by stuff
yeah that would that off top I'm here
depending on what type of control you
seek so like any bylaw is only good as
it's policing so for example if you said
well we want to regulate that you can
only have X amount of cats per property
two or three whatever it might be
well someone's got to check that either
you're reliant on the the police of the
community in other words the community
says well there's a property at such and
such street which we believe has got
more than three cats on it otherwise
you'll have to have probably a dedicated
officer to to actually attend to those
type of things microchipping the same
thing we need to figure out okay how do
we how do we check that cats are
microchipped so there would be a
resourcing aspect to it but again that
if it's it's all I think in proportion
to the perception of the gravity of the
community problem if there's a real
problem there then the community would
support no doubt some resourcing to go
to actually ensure that the problem is
contained
yeah
thank you you have heard of herding cats
it could be a difficult assignment it
may be
if I can ask and and I think it might be
Melanie can you tell us a bit more about
the gore cat rescue Trust
was it or
um I'm not actually part of that oh okay
yeah so probably more injury I think
there was also um what Shona was talking
about so
um there's a collection I'm on the
committee but I don't hold a position on
the uh I'm not the secretary or
financial person I'm just a Committee
Member
um so that's uh that's the same thing
that Shona was talking about setting up
so
um it's just run on a voluntary basis
um trying to desex
surrendered animals whether they're off
the street or somebody's got a little
kittens it
if you don't take these kittens I'm
going to do this this and this with
um and tried to add desex and vaccinated
and re-home them so it's trying to plug
the gap of some of the work that these
PCA done
where do you do it do you need a
box yeah is there a base it the moment
one of the committee members
members and the animals are fostered
through Volunteers in the community
everything's pretty hard without a base
though like Melanie was just alluding to
from it thank you Mr chair
um just a question for Andrea so if your
charitable trust had a base
that's obviously going to take time to
man and basically support so we would
just see your costing coming from and
hit whatever news have you looked at for
funding to help with that
very newly established at the moment
that
it's only just getting off the ground
funding wise
I don't actually know
I hadn't been I missed two of the
meetings with just live stuff going on
um
but basically we asked for donations and
we worked to that sort of thing
yeah we're probably we've only re-homed
about three or four cats because it's
pretty hard it's very very new it's just
trying to establish a foundation to
build on yeah very early days we haven't
been successful in securing any funding
yet mostly because we had to set up the
charitable status and it'll talk time
yeah
Church
G3 you Mr chair
um
why have you not recommended anything
anything like a dog registration such as
a cat registration for
um if we move it into the council side
and to what Steve was saying how it's
funded and how problem sayings it has
resourced and held affect star floating
and that why you not looked at that well
baby States first
so what then do three lady seers the top
priority
well for me dcxn number one
um help with public education
because from what I see personally
there are so many people that just don't
seem to understand why it's so important
and
because I'm out there seeing the end
results
um it's incredibly frustrating
seeing you repeat
kitten advertisers on Facebook and you
know it's it's just a big mess but
um and for me personally a facility
because of the way I work I work from
home and I'm so overwhelmed
inundated you know with requests for
help
I desperately need a facility to
take these cats too so that I can have a
bit of a life back and have our home
back
and get more cats sorted and off the
streets
do we have any other questions from
counselors
Joe
oh yeah thank you um
the
Stray Cats around town
obviously you're able to re-home 100 of
them
I would say probably
95 percent
so far there's been none that I haven't
been able to re-home
um I'm at the moment feeding a couple of
times that I'd like to get desexed money
issues and all that time
exhaustion
those sort of cats are what generally
happens is
you advertise them as possible Barn cats
and you do tend to have quite a bit of
success
with that that on Facebook
so
um
other than that
if that wasn't achievable I'd probably
you know TNR release
D6 release
I guess
so this is like this is a big project
and it's going to take time
right now straight away what the council
can do for you is more around education
is that what you're saying
and working with this process
funding would be wonderful
you know I'm spending a family spending
huge amounts of money doing this which
is crazy
but
um yeah funding
definitely education
facility as I said for me personally
those are the the key things
um some subsidizing desexing or I don't
know what
what can be done there but yeah
okay I'll just check whether any of the
staff have got any questions Steve
thanks Mr chairman just to help the
council
would the community members of the uh
working party just hear a comment on if
funding was made available and if your
number one priority is desexing uh two
things what is uh in your in your
experience the cost of desexing a Tom
and secondly if there was I'm just
saying if hypothetically if there was a
pool of money available do you think
that would remove barriers for people to
desex those Toms or would the toms still
be just left as they are to run amok
just curious
I think that you would need to combine
public education
really really push that
but
to answer your question about cost
Pauline Tinker from a tower of snaps who
runs the snap subsidy desexing subsidy
the cost for desexing a Tom using
Pauline's subsidy is
thirty dollars
and for a female 50. so it makes it
fairly manageable yeah yeah and with the
snip and chip
program that's twenty dollars across the
board so that's pretty amazing too yeah
let's forget it's not humans I'll take
it
any serious questions
[Laughter]
yeah yeah okay
Robert
just one more comment from me
um
is there any way that the SPCA could
come back on board in town or something
like this
is that I have spoken directly with the
manager at Dunedin and she said
unequivocally no they won't be reopening
okay and where do they get their funding
public donations
um
but I do know they made a 38 million
dollar profit last year
it's a good point isn't it
anybody got any connections
all right last call for any questions
from councilors
all right I'd like to turn our minds
then to the recommendations that appear
on page 26 of the report
that are very soon going to pop up on
the screen behind me
know and behold
so there's a series of recommendations
there and what I was wanting to do is is
the deal with the first two together
and the next one talks about
um
establishing a cap management policy and
I'd like to actually deal with that one
last because I have a feeling that some
of the other issues um
included in there might be more better
dealt with as a policy and we can talk
about that as we go through so the the
initial
recommendation is that we received the
report
and think those who represented the
community in the hokanui room on the
working party is there any discussion
relating to those two matters Joe
thank you Mr chair can I just make a
recommendation for a wording change
within the report that instead of using
toxoplasmosis you actually use the
atomic disease because there's a lot of
other diseases that come from cats as
well it can be passed humans
sounds very technical but simple
um
anyway another the ladies at the end of
to help us out on that know anything
more or do we rely on our local expert
at the table
you've got you've got toxo you've got
lipto you've got ringworm you've got
tapeworm that can all be passed on from
cats to people so just just a word and
change a more a more simple one okay
something to bear in mind
okay so back to the first recommendation
that's up on the screen then any any
discussion that arises from either of
those two points
appears to be none can I have a mover
and a second or for those please that
the council receive the report and think
those who represented the community
on the working party
um they're moved and I just got a check
that people are on on the formal
committee so brom1 moving and and Stuart
seconding all those in favor say aye
against carried
so we'll come back to the policy one
thing Susan if we can go down to the
next one
um so the the recommendation here is
that the council enables the council's
grant subcommittee to consider
applications for funding by individuals
and community supports to list a range
of
points that are raised there any
discussion arising from it
well thank you Mr chair I think in
amongst that discussion we need to have
some
um costings around what this would cost
the rate payers of Gore and so that that
can be discussed and fully understood
before we have
um the
the
policy and Regulatory
people you know
charging off and committing us to
something that we can't afford if I can
help by seeing the report there's
reference to between 16 and 20 000 a
year where it's indicated that Public
Funding of half of that would be of
assistance eight to ten thousand we I'm
just worried about the fact I'm looking
at cat shelter
um apart from the six and I mean running
a cat shelter itself may also become
quite expensive like in the actually
having a personal space
separate space but anyway in any other
comments
from the table
I've got a question for the chief
executive and that is that in terms of
the operations of the grants committee
is there any impediment for any group
actually applying for a grant do we need
a a specific resolution or a resolution
that merely notes that application can
be made to the subcommittee
uh through Miss Cheer no there's no uh
impediment for anyone to apply for a
council Grant any one time we have a a
dedicated application form which any
applicant is obliged to fill out and
then goes to the grant subcommittee for
consideration however what this
committee can do if it chooses to is to
signal
a receipt of attitude towards receiving
such an application if you like if you
if you feel that emboldened towards uh
trying to and I'm saying that it might
be that some aspects of the
recommendations put before you and I'm
referring to say desexing
um you may want to invite the group to
put forward an application for an annual
pool of funds that can be dedicated for
desexing and it might make a decent
impact while you're going back to
council Reed's point of view when it
comes to things like cat shelters
there's a capital cost and there could
be well be an operating cost they need
to be carefully assessed but the
desexing could be achieved to a degree
Anyway by a dedicated pool of money and
you know thirty dollars a a ton 200
times a year six six thousand dollars it
won't break the bank but it could
actually really break or make an impact
in terms of ultimately trying to contain
the growth and Cat population for
example
any further comment from Joe
Justin to help reduce populations you
actually Target the female solid species
so bet money if you were doing the D6
thing just do the females and you do a
bit more what's up this one Tom and they
can be the father of many warm uh cats
yes
foreign
any other comments
Venus I um thank you Mr chair I think
desexing the toms might be a good thing
all of them then you don't have
um
any further issues may I suggest that if
if we are to proceed that we just use
deep sexting without gender application
um
laughs
what is the feeling around the table
given that the presentation is
highlighted that d6ing is probably the
number one issue
and and given that the third item that
is there referring to a couch shelter
there's an age of capital item what's
the feeling around the table in terms of
having a recommendation emotion that
refers specifically to desexing was
would there be support for something
like that
feedback please
just around desexing is there any
International Information around how
it's working like
they've gone to specific project
somewhere over a number of years just
sexing cats and they've noticed the
population coming back because they're
in the international or local or
anything on that information
I don't know any hard statistics other
than just what I see
um I mean you don't see as many down the
main street now as you used to probably
thanks to the work that Mel's doing
sometimes the prevention's either than
cure proactive rather than reactive
when I first started doing this there
was a quite a huge colony of cats
down by the ram statue
and now that you know there's probably
about six on average every night
that I've still got to get to but
um so it's a lot less
any other feedback
thank you
Miss thank you Mr chair just one thing
I'm wondering if if um counts could
actually support funding applications
for a cat shelter because I I just feel
like it's not fair to like Melanie to be
housing these cats in her own home
um
that just can't continue I I do
understand the stress that that's put
her under
um I wonder if that's a possibility
any other comment with regard to that
counselors
John
the new dog pound is any sort of room
there or is it so not going to work with
dogs and cats but I mean you'd have to
have just a better soundproof room to
put the kids
yeah
three Mr chair know that the dog pound
was specifically designed for dogs
um and while there is potentially peps
and land there that that could actually
be developed I think I think even the um
the working party members particularly
the community working party members
would Aver that you need to have a
dedicated facility for cats but you know
potentially that could be a site and
that General facility where you could
have a cat shoulder potentially but um
no I think we we were very careful about
designing the the
um dollar pound for just dogs and the
Contemporary needs of dogs and their
cats would be something something
different again
but I think I think Mr chairman had
behold us if we think
if you think that a cat shelter is
something that may be desirable in
principle it's something that perhaps
needs to be taken away as a separate
project teased out what is the need what
is what does it look like
citing costs operations and then come
back to this committee for further
evaluation
Wonder flowing from that
given that we we have put in place our
plan for the year but we're working on a
long-term plan
um whether there would be some support
around the table to word emotion to the
extent that as part of the long-term
plan consideration be given to
options for
um
establishment of a cat shelter can I
have some feedback on that notion and
then I could if there is support I'll
put it as a formal motion
cleanness
I would support that Mr chair but I'm
just wondering um with learning they're
having the knowledge of SPCA that have
38 made a 38 million profit I'm just
wondering if it would be worth
approaching them for some funding for a
cat shelter like you know you may have
picked up the subtlety of the words that
I used of talking about options for and
when you hear that sort of number then
clearly given the statute or the um
purpose of the SPCA
you would think that there is a strong
case to go to them and seek some input
if if people are comfortable I'd like to
um if counselors are comfortable I'd
like to actually put in the form of two
motions of what we have here and and the
ladies are more than welcome to provide
comment as well and the first is that
the council invite applications
is going to come up on the screen
and leave Council invite applications by
an appropriate organization
that then wouldn't be just by the public
to the council's grants subcommittee
seeking funding for the desexing of cats
so hard to return so is there any
comment in terms of that as emotion and
opportunity for input
um
thank you Mr chair I do note that the
word there the second part consider
applications for funding by individuals
and Community groups to support
um
if we had the charitable trust apply and
then Melanie as an individual
I wouldn't want to see one or the other
knocked back when they're doing a good
job I mean how do we
you know what would we do how do we know
that one person or one group isn't going
to apply for a massive amount of funding
get it and then we're short
and then the individual who's been doing
the work at the coal face as well is not
supported
and and I think what that highlights it
is a valid point and I'll play with the
wording in a moment
um it is clear there are times when we
need to have a contestable fund
available and and telling people there
is a contestable fund
um and inviting applications for the
allocation of that fund
um but that's that's behind the scenes
stuff so what you're indicating is that
the council invite applications by
um
uh individuals and Community groups
instead of an appropriate organization
does that pick up the tone of where
people are at and be acceptable
if it is could I have a mover please
from when
anglinous II is there any further
discussion on that
so I'll put the motion all those in
favor say aye
against
carried
the second part that arises from that is
then in relation to
um the
uh I guess the the kick shelter notion
is there support around the table for
actually looking at the issue of a
shelter or premises of some sort
Robert
just
does council actually own something
that's almost fit for purpose it would
not cost a lot of money to repurpose
Mr chief executive
just off the top of here
uh through cheer I can't think of
anything that we have that
and look I'm I'm no expert on cat
shelters but these days animal welfare
and the associated regulation of it is a
higher standard than what would have
been back in the day yeah
so really
I yeah I mean why I think we'll have
land that could accommodate the shelter
the actual building or construction
shoulder I think your fire would need to
be purpose constructed to take into
account the modern welfare regulations
and the modern expectations of the
community about how animals are kept and
controlled so off the top of the head I
can't think of anything that would would
suitably Adept itself to a dedicated
catch holder thank you
is Shelley excuse me I just have to
leave
time
and it'll look exciting to see what
comes out of it thank you for being here
and thank you for your importance
greatly appreciated
so any other thoughts around the table
in terms of cat shelter or
the like
where do people sit is it something that
would be
support for the council investigating or
not
yes Mr chair I would support an
investigation into a cat shelter
doesn't mean that we have to go ahead
with it but it is worthwhile looking
into
in the long term plan
any other views around the table
many other people who would support or
otherwise Neville
thank you Mr chair well as as a member
of the cat wearing party and being this
conception I just gotta um just been
telling you listening
to some of the views but I believe it's
it's council's responsibility to do
something aggressively quickly about
about what's happening
um
we're lucky that we've got some
dedicated group of people out there
doing a really
a great job in in keeping your
population down at their own expense
I think we're sort of like jumping the
head of air sales I think we should be
supporting the establishment of a
working party
our operational group management group
first and given giving them the terms of
reference about what what what to come
forward
and as part of the term of reference it
could be that they recommend in the
long-term plan for a permanent childhood
for cat thing to go go ahead
um and and part of the advanced
investigation they may decide that no
look it currently at this time it's not
it's not viable but we want support upon
desexing feeding help feeding the
animals and looking after the the group
that's doing it at the moment so
I think we I think it's part of the
recommendation that we should just move
along from the the the the operation
under the cat shelter and the cat
fostering Network and put it in as part
of the recommendation for the group
thank you for that what you've raised
really is the question that I had
um for councilor Dixon is what is the
best process for looking at it is it the
long-term plan or is it some further
working party
um
some thoughts please
I think it's the working party rather
than the long-term plan it's the
long-term plans going into a lot of
other things that and just get lost and
in the big bigger picture so if you want
to if you want to progress this thing
the really the only way is to is to do
it through a specialized group
there's so many things we're going to
look at in a long-term plan
that it'll just get lost so if you want
something happen go with your Specialist
Group any other feedback Joe I um
support Stuart's views on that there
and if that was a move around moved
around the table we have a further
recommendation which is Nixon I think in
the list to actually talk about a
working party so um
may be appropriate to move on to that
sorry
oh Steve
yeah Mr just to offer a slightly
contrary opinion so you've got a working
party here that's actually submitted a
suite of recommendations yes what I
think you need to do is say yeah these
are the recommendations that we either
endorse or we endorse in principle or we
want further work done and then I think
the the ltp and the working party or
officer-led analysis with
working party members in tow they all
arrive at the same place the ltp because
ultimately what goes in the ltp has to
be supported by some type of evidence
about
benefit cost how it how that particular
project
Stacks up with other initiatives that
are in the pipeline for consideration so
I'm not sure whether a working party
just say oh you go and do the cat
shoulder I think it might be better to
say well if we think a cat shoulder is
of some Merit then it is actually the
subject of its own
specialized investigation and to come
back to the council for consideration in
tandem with the community of working
party members and then a further debate
is held on the merits that project and
it's either endorsed rejected or
whatever but I'm not so sure just
putting it to working party is going to
deliver the result you need because
ultimately it has to come to council
with some backing and has to go into ltp
mix of because when we get to ltp and
workshops there will be one around
capital projects what goes in what goes
out and also timing maybe it can't
happen this year but maybe it can be
procedural for a little further down the
track but that's part and parcel of our
ltp debate about what's what are your
priorities and how can you wrestle with
the the rates increases you're
predicting versus the community
priorities and where the stacks up in
priority and unfortunately it has to go
up against other things too and we can't
fund them all but that's the ltp is the
center point for consideration of where
this project fits or does not fit thank
you for that
um
and
uh
what what you've described that I'm
interpreting is that if if we highlight
indicating that this can be looked at as
part of the long-term plan then when it
becomes before Council we can get
whatever advice we want from Community
people
um to
um
drill down in a bit more detail
compare that to a working party which
could well
get a bit more into the nitty-gritty but
have a life of its own so listening to
you my thought is that in fact referring
it to the long-term plan will enable a
more focused consideration and get a
consideration of actually achieving an
outcome quicker
um any other feedback around the table
Stuart see my thoughts are taking it
away from the the working uh the
long-term plan was this like the cat
shelter could be funded by grants from
outside organizations so it's I don't
see it as a council alone thing we may
lead the initiative in some way but I
would see other groups maybe the MLT
Community Trust the South and SPCA
everyone banging in some money to make
it work so we might only be the a 10
shareholder in this thing not not that
not the 90 or 100
founder of it so your eyes just going on
that lead that we wanted to get it
outside and
maybe we put a wee bit of money in the
long-term plan but it won't fix the
problem because you might need half a
million to fix this problem we might
only want to put 50 000 in and there are
several projects in the long-term plan
that get funding from outside of council
as well
um so I I take from your comments then
that you would support something
highlighting with referring to us in the
context of the long-term plan
any other feedback
and we'll turn that into emotion I think
of some sort
um so so what comes to mind and open to
guidance from from people really then is
that
um the that the council
uh
uh consider options
for
the establishment
of
um
I'm trying to keep it general of of
facilities
or
housing of cats for the establishment of
facilities for the management of
catch
let's just see how it goes
as part of the long-term plan
process
comments from councilors or staff in
terms of what we've ended up with there
is that something that's acceptable
Steve
probably miss cheering you might want to
say
that a separate report be commissioned
on the merits of of the the feasibility
and costs associated costs including
both Kaplan operating
associated with the establishment of a
cat
shelter facility in the gore district
for considerations part of the long-term
plan process
thank you that's helpful any any
feedback with regard to that please
nodding of several people around the
table
so if we can just end up with that on
the one page
thank you
so
um
sorry yes problem
um one thing that was requested or
mentioned in the report was the
microchipping of cats is that something
that we need to look at in that
long-term plan as well
or is that just a step too far well I
think this is this is probably a a key
issue maybe one that we should have
talked about later uh sorry earlier
we're just the council's responsibility
lie
and the government is considering a
petition
um asking for
registration and microchipping of cats
is my understanding of what's there and
until governments actually made a call
on that whether it's something that the
territory authorities like Gore should
be looking at we don't know
um and I saw
that issue as one that probably Falls
within the policy
the council could prepare
so if we see it if Government doesn't
Advance it
and we see it as something that's
desirable we could include us in the
council policy
sounds like a plan given that it was
before government in November 2021 and
we've heard nothing since
could also get lost in the midst of time
or never eventuate
yeah
Mr chairman just to reiterate endorse
what you just suggested look uh if it's
a cap management policy or and a kit
management or animal control bottle that
that comes from that that's a non-ltp
issue that that's part and parcel of the
council's Regulatory and policy domain
which can be actioned at any time it
sees fit the key thing with the cat
shelter is that it's a capital project
and whether we have a small part or a
larger part of of that project
if it doesn't get
considered as part of the ltp then that
concept rear and reality then lies on
the shelf for another three years to
four years before the next ltp is
reviewed so it's timely that at least it
gets a chance to be considered amongst
the other projects the council will
grapple with come November December this
calendar year so but the the regulatory
settings
they can be acted upon by council at any
given time and it's not tied up with the
ltp
thank you for that important any further
comment then on the wording of the
resolution that that sits on the screen
there
if all are happy can I have a mover and
a second are then moved by councilor
Dixon glennis
second
Stuart
any further discussion
I'll put the motion then all those in
favor say aye
against
carried
the next recommendation refers to a cat
Management Group
and
any comment on this recommendation
please
I have a question for you to think about
and there's along the lines of
it talks about having a shared strategy
and sharing information
um
the strategy I think
is almost part of a policy sharing
information doesn't need to be through a
cap Management Group in my view it's
something that I I would expect that our
our
um I was going to say marketing team our
our PR people were able to
provide links once they were aware of
and just wonder whether a cap Management
Group will actually achieve productive
out
um outcomes that can't be achieved
through a policy
feedback please
Venus
excuse that group not already set up
like we've already got a charity set up
by the community
I think it's a valid point we we have in
charity that that is hoping to do and
already starting to do some good work
that comes from a good sound background
of I guess experience
um
hell would setting up this group take it
any further
and maybe the ladies at the end might
want to comment on that
is is there an advantage of if we would
have a policy
and and we've got the trust there is the
advantage any advantage in having
another group
views around the table
let's do it I don't think was an
advantage having another group those
people uh got the skin in the game and
on the ground that they'll do it if they
want some information distributed then
that they can come and see Sonia at the
council or something and put it in a
newsletter or something even if they
wish or links on the website yeah
and the odd thing turning up on the
antenna
which is useful any any thoughts now
that you've thought about it for 30
seconds
sorry to put you on the spot for your
injury
my brain's just juggling lots of things
at once
different approaches
um I thought that it would be quite good
to keep traction moving
the rescue trust is just one facet
I'm not everybody's associated with it
not everybody wants to be
it would be good to have an umbrella
group or organization that
rather than still be fragmented
that's just my thought
but respect your decisions also
I wonder whether in the preparation of a
policy
it may become clearer whether
a group of that type that's listed there
his advantage over Council doing things
itself
Venus
she could always suggest perhaps we have
a representative
join that that group which would keep us
involved and I'm actually I wasn't
offering but
um bullet point four on my notes suggest
that maybe council could have a
representative attending the trust
meetings if if invited
so the council has Representatives on
many Don Council organizations
and um
I think there might be support around
the table that if
invited to trust meetings Council would
potentially look at appointing someone
to do that and we're just about to go
through an exercise looking at groups
that we are represented on and where we
can best survey our time
and there's clearly one counselor here
who has a keen interest in it who may
well volunteer
so if we're to head down that line a
council is happy that probably at this
stage we don't need to proceed further
with the notion of a cap Management
Group
I'm getting nodding
I'm happy with that choice
so we will have that recommendation just
um not proceeding with at the stage
the next recommendation that is there is
to support the development of public
information to raise awareness and again
I see that as a matter that that is
dealt with as part of the council's
normal operations and part of of a
policy
um any views on that
it's probably something we don't need to
have specifically as a motion
so I'm getting nods in in up and down so
um
accepting the body language that I'm
seeing
um happy people happy to proceed on that
basis likewise but we don't need
anything explicit at this stage
no okay
and the the next one is to Advocate the
enactment of national legislation by
Parliament
is it something we need to recognize
explicitly around the table some
feedback please
or is it something that we should deal
with as part of a policy
Robert
how are they going to catch them to
check them
if they're microchipped
well it's
um yeah
Advocate it's not that we're doing it
what what this says is advocating
government to pass legislation
is their support for that around the
table they've been known to pass
legislation before that doesn't work
no just to comment
Hindi
at least with legislation there's some
backing behind it
you can it's easy to come back to
legislation
and wouldn't you say 2021 since they
spoke about it hey
Joe
thank you Mr chair I guess
if we're
advocating for it we're sort of gonna
give him that
government a bit more teeth to actually
act on
diet and we've got a bit of a chance to
influence the outcome from the get-go
so it probably wouldn't hurt to us if
that's
that'll be my um backing on it so would
you like to put that as a motion that
the council advocates for the enactment
of national legislation by parlor
Parliament Etc in terms of what's there
you know what is there a second there
for that
question
as I could possibly
um advocates for meaning what we've
submit to government we put something
towards the select committee what sort
of advocate are we talking about
advocacy are we talking about
I I would view that what would come out
of that if endorsed by counselors that
we would actually write to the
government
advocating for it
I'm happy to move that or second there
second
let's meet Joe are you a member of the
committee no
no so glennis is going to move it do I
have a second after that motion please
Stuart in any discussion
is part of that discussion
That central government paid for it
and don't be lumped back onto local
government that
um yeah I I think that is a wider issue
that is triggered by the review report
that we've got sitting in in front of us
a present on local government
and and as an ongoing problem that uh
probably better dealt with separately I
would think
any other discussion
so we have a motion on the table then in
terms of council advocating the
enactment and National legislation
that's set out there all those in favor
say aye
against
carried
the final one that's there before I
invite anything else people might want
to raise is that the council Advocates
to environment Southland for additional
support and funding for Effective Pest
Management including feral cats within
the gore District
any comment feedback please
counselors
cleanness
I definitely like to move that
it's cheer
before
procedurally yes you can but before you
do
can I just highlight the
um
the environment itself on Pest
Management strategy deals with cats and
with fuel kept in in with stray cats so
there's already a regulatory or or a
provision and place uh in terms of the
position adopted by environment
Southland
for
recognizing the problem and highlighting
methods of control Under The Pest
Management strategy the approach of
environment Southland is that landowners
are responsible for the management of
pests on its own on their own property
so I'm not sure whether we can actually
take it that step further
and seeking
manage sorry
um support for funding
so um Mr chair I'm just thinking about
Donna Moore Park
and who's funding The Pest Control out
there
for feral cats because I believe there's
quite a large amounts of feral cats
being dumped out there and I think it is
environment Southlands role
to deal with those
I wonder if the chief executive can help
us there because I get notes on the
antenna from time to time saying our
Pest Management people are operating in
such and such an area tonight
just just put the um rivets and hears
and possums that's exactly as you say
it's the landowner is then told to
control them so basically environmental
will not fund it you might get some
funding and helping with trapping and
baits
the physical work is yours
so that would fall under the category of
effective Pest Management then they
would fund that
maybe not
no Joe
normally as a landowner you'd have to
pay for it like for rabbits you'd have
to pay for the shooting and and also the
poisoning
um so the same thing would apply was
kept so I would presume but you could
try them
Stevie up to coming today
not with any a great amount of authority
Mr chairman but what I I do think it's
worth the conversation with environment
South and because I do believe that
kits as well feral cats as a pissed kind
of below the radar and this is this will
be the I think the center point of your
approach to government as well that you
know when you when the government talks
about a clean green predator-free New
Zealand more feral cats are in that mix
and need to be and and so there's a a
role for not just the government but the
Regional Council and I don't think we
should be restricting ourselves for
saying well if some private land and
private landowners deal with their own
Pest Management
we've got a a community-wide problem
here and we need a community a regional
wide response and some partnership and
some some people lifting from the
Regional Council and that would be my
suggestion is that the flavor of the
discussion you take to the Regional
Council
thank you I do wonder if um we're going
to have something of that nature whether
it should be both feral and Stray Cats
so having having heard that discussion
Dennis do you want to rephrase or or um
uh the motion you want to put
Mr stew it's quite difficult if you say
Stray Cats because stray cats can
actually mean
companion cats that have wandered from
home and found somewhere else so
I'd like to refer back to Melanie and
Andrea about that
yes that's something there's a there's a
very big difference between stray and
feral and
you know as I've said I've managed to
tame
all of these cats and Gore
um
and a lot of them I think are dumped
pets so I don't really class that as
feral
so
I'll leave you to put your motion then
Joe sorry first
thank you Mr chair
um and Steve might be able to help me
out on this one there is a pretty pretty
policy by 2050 I believe that's been
worked on and a lot of this may fall
under like what you're saying before
might fall under that that cats are to
be contained or
2050 is the the project it's government
funded I've got a sneaky suspicion
though that feral cats are not in in the
list of Predator's name but I may be
wrong
um it's but they need to be if they're
not
yes
um they're definitely not included
would you like to put your motion out in
place
I'll just move the motion that we have
um that the council application for
additional support is set out on
including within the gold district yes
do I have a second for that
Stuart
any further discussion
all those in favor say aye
against
carried
right and now want to return to the
second matter was there in relation to
the establishment of a council policy is
there support around the table then for
the council to have a policy as as
generally set out on the paragraph there
and for this committee to have
responsibility for the preparation of
that policy
I've got one yes
Stuart
I think we need to put something on
paper even if it is just a starting
point with a camp management policy you
know I've had neighbors with 10 or 12
cats and then was held to pay when you
run over one of them and stuff so yeah
you've gotta
you've got a uh have some sort of
controls on animals in town every other
animal you're not allowed you're not
allowed to keep it all those numbers
around it so I think we should start
doing something anyway
Andy
I think if we're going to be pushing for
some sort of legislation we should have
a policy in place
yeah even if the policy said this is
what will be advocating or whatever
we have our policy planner here with us
today Morgan
um
do you need direction from this
committee today or do we ask for a
report
in relation to a policy by the Morgan or
Steve might want to comment
uh three Mr chair I think that
excuse me
um for the policy and Regulatory
committee to provide guidance would be
useful
um however the design of the policy
ultimately will come through come
through uh research and research on
precedented by other councils
Etc so you may feel like you need you
want to and that would absolutely be
great but then of course again research
the creation of the policy will be
reliant on a great many different
factors
a Wonderland for the chief executive
where whether we have a
motion that that then seeks a report
setting out matters that can be dealt
with on a policy so we can give some
guidance
yeah through machine that's the correct
way I think you need a report uh
outlining some of the issues that a
potential Care Management policy might
contain and then with
um to give I guess some staff some
flavorings as to how extensive you want
that policy go to and then Morgan would
go away and do that research and come up
with a more a draft policy would
or maybe some questions
um with seeking some answers before we
get into a draft policy but that's
that's the way I do it to build a lot
with some discussion a separate meeting
um and with our first report would be I
think around some suggested parameters
and and topics for the policy and uh
seek some kind of indicative feeling as
to how deep and far you want to go to
and then we'll come back with a a
further report
so is is a
what's the feeling around the table to
that approach
generally nods thumbs up is is what I'm
seeing so we therefore could have a
motion that um uh that a report be
prepared for the policy and Regulatory
committee you can go further up
oh yeah policy and Regulatory committee
for the development and Adoption of a
cap management
policy
and it probably can be just left in
simple terms like that
so any any feedback from counselors or
staff in terms of nice simple wording
like
cleanness
um Mr Chicken can I just say to Morgan
that has been a lot of research done by
in Maxwell
um on this that is included in the
report quite thorough research as well
at other councils and
different organizations that could be
helpful
thank you
my things to you that's that's correct
and the answer report is very good
um but of course
it will be related another angle of
research to determine the flavor of
course and we want the widest brick
possible so that we can make a policy
that suits uh the characteristics of the
school district and whatever may be
required for that and of course again
the report goes into detail but yeah to
to shore up the foundations well would
be the way to put it
all right any any other feedback comment
around the table in terms of a
motion of that
type
appears to be none
um can I have a mover and a second and
then for that lotion
I will move it
and can I have a second
Stuart well done thank you any further
discussion
all right all those in favor
say aye
against
carried
are there any other matters that arise
from the report that councilors wish to
raise for consideration at this time
just to reaffirm the work that you
ladies are doing and how much it's
appreciated I know the toll it takes and
um
well done you ladies
any other comments appear to be not
so that draws us to the end of the
meeting I will therefore thank the
ladies present for your efforts